moment again chuck schumer took to the
senate floor for a victory lap
with a twist we have come to an
agreement
for final passage of the bipartisan
infrastructure
proposal as we move forward we're
proceeding on both tracks
the track of the bipartisan
infrastructure proposal
and the track of the budget resolution
with reconciliation instructions just
what nancy and aoc
wanted but wait when he said that
double track thing it's impossible
because just last week
so-called republican senator bill
cassidy of louisiana
told me something very different we
think this makes that behemoth less
likely to pass
and somehow you are trying if i may
leave if a mailbar
if i may we make that bill less likely
to pass
but if we sink this bill and you marry
them together
it's more likely to pass okay that's
just what simple logic tells you
who was right and who was wrong joining
me now with a final warning as
louisiana senator john kennedy serves on
the senate budget committee
and he voted properly on this particular
so-called infrastructure
bill senator uh your message tonight to
your 18 or so colleagues
uh who took this uh path to help biden
threw him a lifeline and now we see
what's going on going to 3.5 trillion
now
well i can just share with you my
perspective laura
early on i i was a likely yes on this
bill i mean you know who's not for
infrastructures
i'm for children and prosperity too but
then i got a copy of the bill and i
realized pretty quickly
that if you look up stupid stuff in the
dictionary there's a
there's a picture of this bill uh
they told us it was a real
infrastructure bill
it's not only 23 of the bill is
real infrastructure the rest is green
new deal
and welfare they told us the bill was
paid for
it isn't we're going to have to borrow
maybe up to 400 billion dollars to pay
for it
they told us there was no there were no
tax increases
there are my state's going to have to
pay 1.3
billion dollars in new taxes on our
petrol chemical industry
uh they told us as you pointed out that
uh the the democrats were were really
wary of this bill
and that it would if we passed this bill
it would make it harder for them to pass
their
five trillion dollar tax and spending
binge
reconciliation bill well if that's true
how come every democrat
voted for this infrastructure bill and
finally they told us that
it's not going to add to inflation but
it will
so why what happened with your 18
colleagues i went through that list
and maybe with exception of a couple
senator
i would say it was pretty much the same
people who wanted jeb bush to be the
nominee in 2016. it was kind of like a
venn diagram it was mostly jeb bush
people
which is fine but mitt romney was
actually arguing that this thing
would save 500 billion dollars
so you're saying this the cbo agrees
with you
but they're arguing numbers that are
just false what is that going to do
uh to the credibility of the republican
party on fiscal responsibility going
forward sir
well i i don't i don't know why it
passed with 60
plus votes um i don't know day drinking
and maybe
[Applause]
all i know is for example inflation
alone which is a horrible tax on middle
america
they told us all this isn't going to add
to inflation but it is
i mean i don't like to brag about all
the expense
expensive places i've been but earlier
today i went to the gas station
this bill's going to make it worse it's
going to make it worse for groceries too
and and look i'm for infrastructure i'm
just not for infrastructure at any cost
i'm for infrastructure i'm not for
infrastructure no matter what
and we're going into a fight now with
the democrats over raising
the debt ceiling and the arguments and
taxes and taxes and the argument that
that
i'd like to make is which i can make uh
this
uh senator schumer this debt is yours
this debt is yours but the truth of the
bit of the matter is that uh
on this last bill the infrastructure
bill this debt belongs to both democrats
and republicans yeah well senator
first of all we appreciate your common
sense approach to this
it's common sense it's it's facts versus
fiction and we appreciate that
the republicans gave joe biden a
lifeline
and i can't tell you how angry so many
people are out there
about that one fact it's fraudulent and
it's false
and all 18 think they're going to skate
for six years
they're not people are going to have a
long memory about this senator thank you
thank you for being here hey sean
hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else